présenté ce week-end en marge du
festival de cannes le film rodéo crée
déjà la polémique
ce long métrage signé lula qui vaut rond
qui fait la promotion des rodéos n'est
pas du goût de tout le monde
irresponsable et débile cette pratique
est extrêmement dangereuse et rodéos
urbains font chaque année démarre les
rodéos cette discipline artistique qui
consiste à faire des figures sur des
motos lancé à pleine vitesse plus
récemment c'est un jeune garçon de 5 ans
qui a frôlé la mort en se faisant
renverser à pantin le rodéo urbain a
fait une victime ce dimanche un jeune
garçon de cinq ans a été percuté par un
groupe de quatre jeunes qui roulait à
très vive allure la réalisatrice la
polémique n'est pas là les accidents il
y en a c'est sûr comme dans n'importe
quel sport extrême mais la plupart c'est
quand ils sont pris en chasse par les
forces de l'ordre alors le phénomène des
rodéos urbains s'intensifie en france
faut-il créer des espaces dédiés
des espaces dédiés là oui non oui non
non non béatrice non merci saluer parce
que ça réglera pas le problème la
plupart de ces jeunes sont dans la
transgression dans la provocation est
donc en fait on pourra créer tous les
espaces qu'on veut c'est pas le c'est
pas le sujet pour et continueront à le
faire dans des endroits interdits parce
que c'est bravé l'interdît qu'il est qui
les dérangent en revanche le film ne me
pose aucun problème parce que l'art
n'est pas fait et le cinéma n'est pas
fait pour faire la morale aux gens en
revanche les propos de la réalisatrice
qui dit que l'essai la police qui
poussent ces jeunes vers la mort ça je
trouve ça scandaleux
alors j'ai une vertu c'est honteux ce
que je viens d'entendre
ces bobos du festival de cannes qui se
glorifie d'un film je ne veux même pas
parler de sa qualité mais qui parle des
rodéos urbains même si c'était de l'art
comme si c'était un sport c'est
absolument honteux mais comment on peut
faire ça il ya des gens qui souffrent
vous le disait il ya un enfant qui a été
renversé à pantin par des gens à 60
kilomètres/heure il ya des dizaines
d'engins saisis par la police qui est
beau heureusement beauce et c'est vrai
que les accidents c'est pas causé par ce
qu'ils sont poursuivis ces causes est
parce qu ils font n'importe quoi qui
c'est de la provocation je vous rappelle
que c'est un an de prison un an de
prison à rodéo urbain donc ce film qui
glorifie ça me scandalise alors
justement
la réalisatrice en a parlé un instant
lola qui n'auront qu'à des actions les
accidents sont souvent causés par les
filles qui prennent en chasse et je suis
très une forme de précarité qui poussait
rider la mort
alors il ya le débit selon l'excellent
david lisnard merde et exceptionnel qui
dit qui lui a répondu avec l'équipe de
la police municipale nous n'avons pas
été convaincus par les propos de cette
dame qui ressemble un sketch des
inconnus nous allons continuer de
poursuivre arrêter les auteurs de rodéo
urbain notre match hier à son oeuvre
voilà c'est vrai que ma soeur c'est fou
d'en dire ça franchement oui mais là où
le béa trice à raison l'art n'est pas
l'alpha l'art après on n'a pas le juger
à la célèbre la délinquance
qui célèbre jeu le rendait de la
violence tu regardes de 40 hinault il
est alors très ya de la grogne à des
viols et des trucs bien c'est la
même chose j'ai vu des trucs rocher
suchard jeter comme ça en revanche là où
béatrice a tout à fait raison c'est les
propos hors du film de la réalisatrice
pose question quand la rédactrice 10 bat
le seul problème de ces rodéos c'est la
police et balles à ramon tourner parce
que c'est ça n'a rien à voir moi je suis
scandalisée par ce que dit valérie mais
comment vois-tu scandalisé parce que non
mais cyril jamais vraiment tu peux dire
c'est du cinéma j'ai eu mon peut
autoriser un film qui fait l'apologie de
rodez
ce cas là les films sur les serial
killers amène un petit
animal tu fais pas mais ça c'est de la
fiction la salle c'est que la danse tout
risque n'existe pas
[Rires]
mais demain il va dire demain tu vas
faire l'apologie du slip rouge avec
superman mais rejoint nommé à l'aise au
real et spider-man n'existe pas j'en
vois une araignée avait pas de sauter à
la gorge oui oui madame moi je suis
d'accord avec 100% avec tout ce qu'elle
a dit béatrice d'abord pour l'aspect le
cinéma hausse à quoi sert à la baisse
apparente et ça c'est beau ça commence à
fitou
destiné à quand un voyage aux etats unis
vous allez faire toute la cordillère des
andes non mais quand même plein d'amour
une gamme bardot et jeanne moreau reste
dans les analyseurs
[Rires]
la part des crises et les phénomènes de
société en plus au niveau de la
réalisation le film a l'air sublime donc
évidemment pas de morale là dessus en
revanche mais c'est absurde de penser
qu'on peut encadrer les rodéos vous
pensez franchement que les dalton si on
va leur donner des heures et des jours
mais et des lieux je les verrai 21 seas
qui dure et ses bras mais bon
c'est la raison l'élection de quoi tu
vas aller wattrelos tu vas faire un
circuit ça te fait chier
mais je ne peux pas cautionner ça c'est
interdit je n'ai pourchassés et non mais
là quand on sait que la police n'a pas
le droit de les poursuivre oui mais ça
va
nico mais allah pour la [ __ ] pour la
plupart ils elles sont mineures donc si
on encadre le truc on met des terrains
exprès n'est circuit exprès pour ça je
pense que ça peut être c'est forcément
mieux ça va
péter seront pourchassés de partout et
qu'ils auront un seul endroit où aller
que sa phrase a comme ça n'oubliez pas
qu'aux états unis il y avait le problème
des royaux de voiture et qu'ils ont fait
ça la police les a encadrés que ça a été
sur des lieux dédiés des parkings des
trucs comme ça qu'ils essayent dédié
maman il ya eu moins d'accidents écoute
du coup elle s'était un peu plus encadré
même s'il n'ya pas de rétroviseur il ya
souvent pas de permis à rien et je
t'explique mais la patte moi là je suis
complètement d'accord et qu'il a dit là
dessus je vous dis oui les trucs dédié
ça marche on
pouvait les sont baptisés les voilà
tous des délinquants qui étaient là pour
faire du mal au dos et pas du tout en
réalité mort a longtemps
c'est ton fils mais bien sûr mais
arrêtez d'être démago s'est pas fait non
pas vraiment quand il peut avoir un fils
avec un guide
le cros bitume les rodéos à une vraie
culture c'est des jeunes qui ont des
valeurs qui veulent se faire entendre
est-ce que des dérapages effective des
valeurs accident qu'il faut les
condamner je pense que c'est très
exactement les encadrer pour que c'est
cette saison mais l'attaqué de vendredi
c'est sur la question la question elle
est simple c'est pas moi qui les posent
et moi je sais même pas qui avait sa
faute il crée des espaces dédiés aux
idées oui je vous dis que ça ne change
rien c'est quoi tu roules tu peux
toujours des groupes qui fait 10
attendait aussi très bon goût de chasse
et pêche
non mais si tu as envie dans l'utopie de
faire croire aux gens qu'on va créer des
espaces à 30 50 kilomètres des villes
dans des champs parce qu'il faudra le
faire loin des villes les espaces
vierges au diable vauvert les parents
non mais tu es fort interdisait de créer
les espaces tu voulais créer ou les
espaces
dans des parkings loin des villes tu
crois que le mec il va prendre des
rendez vous c'est spontané quand ils
sont arrivés bécane elec les mecs il est
minuit vont chercher les mécanismes
mécaniques font des roues en pleine
journée ce qui les intéresse c'est de
faire ça en ville la réalisatrice là qui
dit oui c'est pas grave faut les laisser
faire c'est la police elle n'habite pas
dans les villes où il ya des rodéos
sinon elle serait script ou rire la vie
elle serait pas pour parce que les
rodéos ça pourrit la vie ça fait du
bruit des bécanes ça empêche les gens et
c'est dangereux laviec le gamin et quand
tu dit guillaume faut les laisser
s'exprimer les français on leur dit de
mettre la ceinture on leur dit de rouler
à 50 il ya des règles tenté sur une
route il ya un code de la route ils
peuvent pas arriver comme ça et le mec
qui a fait un gros il va s'en plaindre
et sur mon camion on fait quoi alors
c'est très dangereux pour eux et c'est
très dangereux pour les garder un côté
c'est pas un jeu et les espaces si vous
voulez dire oui on va leur créer des
espaces pour faire du bien aux gens oui
si vous pensez mais c'est de l'utopie
les mecs qui prennent la bécane comme ça
ils vont faire des tours comme ça non
pourquoi deux rendez vous à 100 pour
aller faire termine quand
brodeur
c'est le petit comme les gens qui
habitent pas
manuel sa mère trop de gens qui
n'habitent pas des gens qui n'habitent
pas où il ya les rodéos qui sont
premières ayant évidemment ils vont se
dire oui il faut les laisser vivre quand
tu habites dans des trucs c'est pas fini
j'ai pas fini
tu nous as houlès daniel est justement
je rebondis sur le bruit parce que cette
réalisatrice quand même je dis qu'il
fallait ce qui était intéressant c'est
de comment tu t'en par du bruit pour te
faire entendre c'est à dire que soi
disant ils font du bruit pour se faire
entendre parce que ils sont malheureux
enfin voilà donc là on a la totale et
moi je voudrais me reviendra quand il
peut être
ce qui me gène le film il a le droit
d'exister c'est une avant de fixer leurs
heures de vivre évidemment on peut pas
remettre ça en temps passes tu à mai que
cette année non coup de poing c'est le
risque avec
ce film qui sautait fureur de vivre et
on est c'est vrai c'est le regard des
séries il dit n'a que l'on
connaissait pas tous égards mais avec
des milliers de films qui sortent qui
sortent maire fasse un solo un coup de
projecteur le 46e ligne je veux lui
laisser la parole je voudrais juste moi
qu'on ait une pensée pour cette dame de
77 ans qui est morte 26 août 2021
percuté de plein fouet par un motard qui
faisait des roues arrière est le
traverser sur les clous et elle est
morte et j'ai entendu le lendemain
quelqu'un de sa famille pleurait s'est
passé dans l'indifférence générale c'est
sûr communisants souvenait pas voilà et
on a quelqu'un qui dit qu'en fait c'est
des policiers qui vient dire qu'ils sont
dans le match si bien dire qu'ils sont
on
dira qu'il faisait du bruit pour se
faire entendre moi j'en ai marre de tout
ça les gens malheureux il fait il faut
pas qu'elle fasse du malheur autour
d'eux il faut qu'il essayait de se
soigner tout tout seul à la voile à
lorient vous m'avez fait le plus parler
je changer ça
oui alors vous laisser bon gilles
c'est un an de prison se recoupent quand
on fait des rodéos c'était pour moi
c'est de ses domiciles passer ces armes
par destination une moto dans les 26 mai
classe et voilà c'est un mort donc c'est
pas ce n'était pas assez puni et ça va
effectivement rien changé sur les
banques un des terreaux jamais non de
les punir beaucoup plus que ce que l'on
prend les 10 ans de taule au fait le
coup dans la rue et maintenant ça va
changer les choses merci sénat puis pour
conclure le dossier il faudrait
sénégalais 2010 à delphi et baltimore
mais tu sais pas tu vas sur wikipédia
[Rires]
wikipedia dans l'émission sachez que je
disais je
m'étais multitude a été tapée s'y
intéresser à la réalisatrice qui a parlé
je vous sers d'interview à cannes et
reste watan